[Musique]
on
bonjour à tous bienvenue au premier live
samsung tv sur la chaîne youtube de
samsung france et de la chaîne youtube
de monsieur greu l'objectif de ce live
et de vous présenter de vous démontrer
de vous expliquer de manipuler les
produits samsung télé et les produits
sont alors je suis pas tout seul pour le
faire pendant cette heure que je vais
passer qu'on va passer avec vous je suis
avec un créateur de contenu je suis avec
un expert de l'audio vidéo je suis avec
monsieur gros salut guillaume salut
aurélien quand vas tu écoute bien très
heureux d'être là avec vous merci pour
l'invitation alors merci pour une
passion réciproque parce
qu'effectivement on est sur votre chaîne
youtube comme tu le disais en direct on
également chez moi donc vous m'invitez
chez vous je vous invite chez moi c'est
un partage et je trouve ça beau tout à
fait donc déjà merci de nous apporter ta
caution d'experts merci de nous
présenter tes 5 121 mille abonnés
quelque chose près à quoi je crois que
c'est plutôt une bonne chose et alors on
se connaît pas beaucoup oui je crois que
tu es plutôt un expert sur la partie
smartphones chez samsung exactement
exactement on s'est vu deux ou trois
fois mais justement ce qui m'intéressait
dans ce live c'est que tu puisse nous
donner ton avis un peu critique un peu
extérieur de nos produits c'est d'autant
plus important que ce live il est fait
par les équipes samsung s'est un peu
fait par nous même tu vois des personnes
passionnées passionnante on va le voir
après les chefs de produits et mon
directeur marketing donc c'est vrai
maison quoi voit ses maisons à l'arrêt
et cette caution mrg re est plutôt très
intéressant et ben moi je suis heureux
d'être là et puis ce qu'on va voir plein
dedans je connais déjà tout le programme
on a déjà tout regardez là tout préparés
parce que ça fait un petit moment qu'on
bosse dessus est resté bien connecter
jusqu'à la fin parce que vous allez voir
c'est super intéressant et donc rester
connecter jusqu'à la fin mais surtout
inscrivez-vous dans une logique dans une
routine de live puisque on va répéter
cette exercice tous les mois ok et donc
le mois prochain à peu près dans la
troisième semaine d'avril on va refaire
un live ou là on présentera des produits
lifestyle tv alors lifestyle chez nous
c'est quoi ce sont des télés mais qui
sont un peu différentes des télés qu'on
connaît c'est à dire l'écran noir qu'on
a chez soi ça peut être le frère de
sérum et on en parlera un peu après donc
vraiment on a une logique tous les mois
d'avoir ce live ensemble hyper cadeaux
voilà et donc aujourd'hui donc comme tu
l'as dit qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va
vous présenter trois choses trois
nouveautés qui sont pour moi importante
ensuite on va parler de gaming on va
voir que le gaming explose aujourd'hui
en france due au confinement et ensuite
on va vous parler du son de la barre de
son cette association nécessaire entre
la télé et justement la barre de son
avoir une expérience complète à la
maison expérience complète à la maison
donc à chaque fois tu interviens lui
nous dit si c'est bien aussi c'est pas
bien de le dire tant qu as tu nous tiens
et ça je pense que c'est important pour
essayer voilà d'avoir une bonne
expérience et soyez clément parce que
voilà c'est notre première c'est la
première il faut commencer un jour donc
ça c'est super voilà alors pour
commencer avant de de d'annoncer florent
qui va venir vous montrer deux trois
choses moi je voulais vous dire vous
présenter trois produits qui font pour
moi extrêmement important que chaque
début d'année on a le cbs consumer
electronic show je crois qu'il était
exactement et on présente nos nouveautés
de 2022 et on a présenté trois produits
qui pour moi sont importants le premier
c'est celui ci voilà c'est le freestyle
c'est le premier vidéoprojecteur
connectés connecter à internet et
portable très atypique très atypique
le deuxième d'ailleurs on est en
prévente on termine les pré ventes
européennes sur ce produit c'est un
succès européen au niveau des préventes
ça a cartonné
on est tombé en rupture très rapidement
donc voilà on court après les pièces ça
c'est un bon signe ouais ça c'est un bon
signe donc ça on va le voir après
deuxième chose c'est à une barre de son
la barre de son que vous voyez ici c'est
une 11 points 1.4 voilà c'est une dolby
atmos wifi sans fil et ça je pense qu'en
termes d'expériences sonores c'est
l'effet waouh ok on va te l'a présentée
après et ensuite la troisième chose le
troisième produit c'est en lien avec la
date d'aujourd'hui le 24 mars
puisqu'aujourd'hui on lance
officiellement sur le marché
notre nouvelle notre deuxième génération
de téléviseurs n'ai aucune aide c'est
une technologie avec des mini l'aide
c'est une dalle très lumineuse avec une
colorimétrie très importante qui fait 1
5 cm d'épaisseur on en voit ici le
produit c'est très bluffant c'est ce qui
nous permet d'être leader depuis 15 ans
justement chez samsung sans cesse
innover et cette année c'est demande une
nouvelle gamme n'ai aucune aide top ok
ouais donc pour justement essayer de te
convaincre sur ces trois nouveautés je
vais appeler florent greffe voilà notre
directeur marketing sur la partie télé
on peut leur dire sa salle et dire salut
rien salut force et le flanc alors par
déjà première chose bon chèque est hyper
passionné donc évidemment tu m'as tout
spoiler alors là je vais essayer quand
même dû de raconter un petit peu des
choses en plus ça je vais juste une
petite correction nous sommes leaders
depuis 16 ans 16 ans jusqu'en 2022
depuis 16 ans
premier produit effectivement le
freestyle on en parlera après un petit
peu ton expérience produits c'est un
ovni unique dans le sens où c'est un
vidéoprojecteur nomades parfait pour les
parents parfaits pour les enfants multi
usages on en revient d'un prêt avec toi
ta propre expérience un son 360°
multidirectionnel super légers 700
grammes et puis on a une image qui est
peut faire 30 à 100 pouces à peu près 80
centimètres à deux mètres cinquante ce
qui est top c'est qu'il est il ce
calibre automatiquement donc à la faune
animale jorhat à la fois des images qui
est rectangulaire et on a aussi un focus
qui permet une mise au point automatique
donc vraiment rien à faire quoi en fait
rien à faire portable vraiment unique
connectés comme le disait guillaume donc
du coup tu peux même faire du gaming tu
peux faire plein de choses mais je crois
qu'on va y être un privilégié parce que
tu l'as pas vu qu'une fois ce produit
non j'ai vu plein de fois on a eu
l'occasion de se rencontrer un paquet de
fois alors c'est super parce que tu
parlais justement du cms tout à l'heure
alors en début d'année effectivement je
la vis au cs mais je les ai vus avant
j'ai vu avant noël sur des prêts brief
sous embargo n'avait pas le droit d'en
parler et quand on l'a rencontré on
était plein de plein de journalistes
médias et tout et on s'est dit qu'un cc
c'est très différent alors on s'est tous
posé plein de questions et moi je les ai
revus après aux 6es et là j'ai fermé ok
tu avais tous les cas d' usage il nous
avait promis dans une tente donc tu
voyais quand et en camping dans une
temps passes tu peux te projeter ton
petit film le soir après s'être baigné
tranquillement tu peux le mettre sur un
mur alors nous a même fait des
installations où il le projetait d'en
haut et tu voyais une table avec les
tables virtuelles avec des découverts
virtuel bref il ya plein de cas d'usagé
pour le projeter et c'est super
intéressant notamment un point important
comme tu disais
c'est justement portable et il ya une
batterie qui va arriver en mai qui va
permettre justement dans une expérience
camping ou dans une tente d'avoir une
autonomie je crois que d'un film c'est
de trois heures c'était trois heures
trois de ses séries tadic dicale
exactement et du côté de moi
d'instruction puisque hors du coup free
style fait les est le nouveau produit
qu'on a dans la gamme lifestyle comme tu
précises de soudeur donc je voudrais
juste rappeler qu'on a trois catégories
de produits chez samsung donc l'été
mehdi classique écran noir qu'on veut
appeler classiquement donc ce sont tous
nos produits du hd recul est donné au
cul l'aide on va parler de recul et de
le qz900 juste après on a nos produits
lifestyle donc le plus connu c'est the
frame donc j'imagine que tu connais
fribourg c'est à dire qu'en fait quand
se fraye m'est arrivé il ya quelques
années on a vu arriver un truc aussi un
peu particulier super intéressant cadre
bois c'est un peu une petite oeuvre
d'art à la maison et je les revues ya
pas longtemps au lourd parce que vous
avez un partenariat avec le louvre pour
afficher les oeuvres du louvre
directement dans sa télé the frame et
ses canons et puis le fait de pouvoir
aller au louvre avec samsung façon un
peu privé avec tête à tête avec la
joconde c'est pas se retrouver chez soi
avec la joconde qui te regarde et c'est
quand même assez impressionnant est
bluffante a l'habitude de voir la
joconde au louvre mais tu passes tu vois
deux minutes là l'avoir 1h 2h toute la
journée c'est un peu pas dérangeant mais
voilà c'était assez impressionnant ouais
d'ailleurs tu parle de l'aspect plutôt
esthétique décoration on dit le frère
m'ont dit que quand le plus discret des
téléviseurs devient le plus beau des
cadeaux et c'est exactement ça
exactement ça et on a plain d'actualité
à courir sur frame on en parlera dans le
prochain live le mois le mois prochain
exactement donc ça c'est un des exemples
des parties live salle on a d'autres
produits 0 qu'on a derrière qui est
vraiment pour les jeunes qui est
connecté qui pivote on a ses riffs qui
va en chic à la française fait part des
frères bouroullec qu'ils sont français
donc on a vraiment cette chance chez
samsung france d'avoir un produit fait
part des français pour le marché
français et d'autres produits la
troisième catégorie c'est effectivement
le sont donc dans le son on a plusieurs
éléments on allait barre de son avec ou
sans qu'ils sont et on a aussi les
sanctuaires les boum boum comme on le
dit chez nous en interne qui seront
effectivement d ultra puissante si on
parle effectivement du deuxième produit
qu'on voulait couvre aujourd'hui qui est
cette barre de son est on aura lorraine
qui viendra parler puisque l experte et
bien plus experte comme moi pour en
parler mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que c'est un tronc 3d blu fin on a
cette technologie 11 points pour un
carton alors pour être très clair le
point 1 1 c'est effectivement le caisson
de basses le point 4 ce sont les hauts
parleurs qui envoie le son au plafond
qui permet de réfléchir et le 11 c'est
effectivement un son qui a envoyé dans
onze directions donc c'est vraiment une
expérience sonore ultime et qui va
parfaitement avec nos télés n'ai aucune
aide qui est du commun transition avec
le qz900 consorts aujourd'hui donc c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on voulait faire le
live aujourd'hui comme l'a dit guillaume
en introduction c'est le lancement de
nouvelles gammes de vie monde 2022 et je
voudrais juste donner quelques petits
éléments sur sur effectivement se
produire donc ça c'est une excellence en
termes de luminosité aujourd'hui on a
des technologies miled donc pour être
pour expliquer un petit peu les mines et
led sont des led qui sont 40 fois plus
petit que les led classiques donc on a
vraiment une précision ou dans l'image
qui est assez incroyable ça nous permet
une super de méditer et du coup un super
contraste évidemment on a une résolution
qui peut faire quatre karoui karoui cas
jusqu'à 33 millions de pixels et en a
une excellence dans l'expérience puisque
je l'expliquais juste avant on à la
technologie du symphony avec les barres
de son et ça effectivement rien ne va en
parler plus en détail on a ce design
ultra-fin qu'on appelle infiniti qui est
vraiment unique sur le marché on a un
boîtier déporté donc là aussi on est on
a plus aucun câble qui viennent polluer
entre guillemets l'esthétique de notre
salon et puis évidemment on a tout
l'expérience smart tv qui bien
évidemment est particulier en pousser
chez samsung là aussi ça fera l'objet
d'un focus dans un live prochain puisque
on aura des annonces à faire on a des
partenariats à venir pour continuer à
enrichir notre expérience je sais pas si
aurélien à cette télé alors j'ai donc je
n'ai pas la maison mais je les ai eus à
la maison je légumes en test un petit
moment et alors c'est vrai que tous les
points que tu décris sont super
intéressant le fait d'avoir le boîtier
déporté ça permet alors soin de mettre
le boîtier derrière qui est planqué
derrière lequel centrale soit devenir
elle l'a posée directement au mur parce
que bien que ce soit quand même énorme
téléviseur on peut venir la fiction
alors énorme là parce que là on a une
grosse bouffée de 75 pouces
l'avoir un peu plus petit ou en un peu
plus grande si si - la fina salle est
dingue parce que là quand on la voit de
façon se rend pas compte mais on la voit
de profil elle est extrêmement fine et
puis il ya plein d'atouts dont tu
parlais alors n'attendons pas parler
c'est la télécommande parce que ça ça
m'a bluffé quand je les ai vus l'année
dernière c'est un truc de dingue parce
que cette télécommande vous n'avez pas
besoin de piles non m c'était mon
dernier point alors costumes spoils
comme aujourd'hui les et la folie
donc là le dernier site étant taxes non
plus mais en tout cas voilà notre notre
troisième partie d'excellence j'ai envie
de dire c'est effectivement l'éco
responsabilité puisque chez samsung
dunaire général c'est très très
important donc on a effectivement une
garantie disant anti marquage sur nos
produits donc vraiment quand on achète
un produit ses rangs pour garder dans le
long terme on force pas au
rafraîchissement on a sept ans de
garantie sur les pièces détachées on a
des packagings on peut en parler qu'ils
sont moches mais c'est fait exprès
puisqu'on utilisant des matières qui
sont recyclables et puis effectivement
les télécommandes on a les a remplacés
donc on a plus de piles elles sont
solaire elles se rechargent notamment
avec les ondes wifi dans la pièce donc
même dans un tiroir sans aucune lumière
elle va surcharger exactement et ça
c'est cool c'est bien et comme il disait
aussi je passe tu l'as vu en magasin non
carton ils sont ils sont marron ils sont
en carton brut sans encre voilà il ya eu
quelques comme tu le disais ça fait
moche c'est moche et c'est ça exprès et
on en est fiers puisque jusqu'au moment
on porte cet éco responsabilité jusqu'au
bout la beauté est à l'intérieur c'est
ça et donc justement donc ces produits
là et notamment les gammes n'ai aucune
aide 2022 d'accord qui se termine par un
b o fin à la fin de la référence sont
son live à partir d'aujourd'hui c'est
exactement site démons et eller et en
magasin et donc pour le live on a un
code promo ça se fait dans l'elite
d'abord à se prendre bien un qui est
valable à partir de maintenant jusqu'à
ce soir minuit minuit d'accord et donc
le code il est associé justement à nous
deux est ce que un c'est samsung et
après gros donc samsung 2g et greu trois
rer c ca de g3 mc facile à retenir vous
avez le site de samsung points comme le
samsung vous allaitez d'été aucune et
oculi dès 2022 on peut mettre le lien
dans la description peut-être la plus
élevée en maître alain des élections et
puis vous mettez samsung re pour avoir
15% de remise sur l'achat d'un
téléviseur 2022 c'est normal
mais l'ailé barre de son q series on le
verra à la fin pas d'accord c'est moi
qui ai exposé c'est toi qui se paye ce
coup là bravo donc merci pour ces trois
produits vous montrer le freestyle la
barre de son est notre nouvelle gamme
n'ai aucune aide maintenant je voulais
parler de deuxième sujet qui me qui a
beaucoup d'importance pour moi c'est le
développement du marché du gaming avec
le co vide tu sais que voilà tout le
monde s'est un peu recentrer chez soi en
famille et le marché du gaming explosé
alors ils avaient déjà explosé 1 je
pense un peu aurélien mais aujourd'hui
on peut dire que le marché du gaming
c'est le premier produit culturel après
le livre la musique et le cinéma ce qui
est quand même extrêmement important et
je crois qu'on joue 8h30 c'est sa
moyenne par an men en moyenne par
semaine donc c'est extrêmement important
et pour moi ça fait d'autant plus d'écho
que florent qui nous a rejoint il ya
quelques temps un mais bien y'a pas si
longtemps que ça vient du monde du
gaming et donc justement pour toi voilà
qu'elle est liée entre la télé et de
guémy alors déjà il ya plusieurs
typologies de joueurs donc
historiquement quand même le gaming
c'était le pc alors du coup on joue
plutôt sur écran pc on n'a d'ailleurs
pas mal des crampes et c'est aussi chez
samsung qui sont très performants mais
ensuite il ya tout un marché de consoles
de consoles ont explosé depuis des
années sur lequel effectivement on joue
sur tv et il ya aussi une troisième
typologie joueur qui est un peu plus
téléphone portable je sais pas toi quel
type de joueur toi c'est toi + moi alors
historique mort avant il y avait
beaucoup les consoles et maintenant
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup sur mobile
comme je teste beaucoup de mobiles j'ai
beaucoup de prétexte pour jouer pour
jouer au shérif en train de travailler
là où je travaille donc on a un joueur
sur vos vies on a un joueur sur après
c'est vrai que j'ai toujours des
consoles j'ai commencé avec sega master
system et megadrive après je passe ici
chez playstation je pense qu'à un moment
on a tous pris la vague playstation donc
à ma génération c'est la génération post
est jeune j'ai passé sur xbox en gt
quand je travaille je suis ubisoft
puisqu'à ce moment là c'est la meilleure
console en termes de technologie et j'ai
eu la chance de rentrer chez microsoft
pour lancer xbox one donc effectivement
j'ai passé dix ans dans un marché du
gaming je suis très attaché donc moi je
me considère en entrant mainstream et
hardcore mais je suis vraiment un joueur
console et sur télé et aujourd'hui je
suis très content du coup de travailler
sur le sur le monde du gaming dans le
monde du gaming mais via le prisme été
comparé vraiment anglais dans le milieu
du gué minium hardcore gamer c'est le
cas jouer le gamer d'accord dompter un
casual gamer je suis entre dans rage
ouais je suis entre meanstream et
hardcore ses débuts quand tu quand tu
regarde mon nombre de sur xbox
d'entendre ce serait hardcore mais je me
considère quand même comme un crime
parce que je joue vraiment classiquement
aux jeux les plus les plus jouées que tu
connais certainement d'ailleurs
bas ce qui est important c'est moi ce
qui est important pour moi c'est de
savoir comment quel est le lien quels
sont les bénéfices à sion en fait de
jouer avec une console de salon sur son
téléviseur on regarde beaucoup voilà la
télé les séries où le cinéma avec un
grand écran comme tu le vois mes donc on
utilise de plus en plus pour le gaming
et c'est comme ça qu'elles sont les
bénéfices de sa donc pour ça on a
recruté il ya quelques mois également un
nouveau chef de produit gaming s'appelle
kevin ouais d'accord qui a mon avis tu
attends pour défier dans la salle d'à
côté c'est ça voilà c'est ça c'est la
jeune génération qui est qui va pousser
la moyenne génération c'est important
donc ça écoute je te propose d'aller le
rejoindre puis de faire une courte pause
le temps de réorganiser tout ça
[Musique]
et nous voilà de retour pour cette
deuxième partie de notre live samsung tv
sur deux plateaux maintenant avec notre
équipe de gamer sur la droite et nous
qui allons admirer leur parti
avant ça je voulais juste vous présenter
kevin comme je les dis juste avant kevin
nous a rejoint il ya quelques mois tu es
notre chef de produit gaming voilà si je
peux dire j'ai deux questions à se poser
kevin la première c est ce que tu es
joueur de pc ou joueurs de console et la
deuxième chose est ce que tu es un
hardcore gamer ou un casual gamer salut
guillaume merci merci pour la petite à
production effectivement et merci florum
avoir rejoint je commence à me sentir un
peu seul dans mon salon alors pour
répondre à ta question guillaume
effectivement moi je joue depuis plutôt
mon salon donc je suis sur consoles de
base donc j'ai eu un peu la même
expérience que florent j'ai commencé sur
playstation 1 puis ps2 après sur pc /
xbox et c'est donc plutôt sur mon salon
surmonter v et puis les week-ends donc
je suis un cageot gamer quand je peux le
soir et que j'ai pas trop de travail
j'essayais de jouer un petit peu donc
c'est plutôt sur des jeux de sport des
jeux de tir ou des jeux de sports
mécaniques ok donc là vous allez vous
affrontez vous montrer un petit peu
qu'elle soit la qualité des jeux et
comment les on les voit comme on les
ressent à travers les téléviseurs
samsung donc je crois qu'il ya trois
jeux puisque florent le challenge et sur
le monde des jeux que je connaissais
d'accord et le premier c'est nba touquet
c'est ça le deuxième c'est au riz et le
troisième c'est gardiens de la galaxie
est exactement et en termes
d'instruction alors quand je parlais des
jeux tout d'abord tu devais connais je
pense à fifa call of duty traoui les
deux plus gros jeux vendus chaque année
et donc nous on est en tant que samsung
on est évidemment agnostique en termes
de consoles et particulièrement toutes
les dernières générations sont
évidemment compatible et qu'une tv pour
cette session particulière aujourd'hui
nos amis d'xbox ont bien voulu nous
prêter une xbox série 6 essais pour le
c'est pour ça qu'on va pouvoir faire la
démo de ses trois jeux là et notamment
henri
oui tout à fait et du coup j'en profite
pour rebondir pour vous présenter en
rentrée un petit peu plus dans le vif du
sujet sur le gaming et l'association
qu'on peut en faire avec les consoles
d'un point important mais je suis
quelqu'un de très impatient florent ne
l'a pas encore vu je viens d'arriver je
l'aimé mais voilà j'aime que ça aille
vite et du coup la chance qu'on a avec
nos tv c'est que en fait directement
alors on va se décaler un tout petit peu
pour mieux le voir alors on a eu la
chance parce que xbox nous a prêté sa
console et donc du coup ici on a un
accès rapide les téléviseurs n'est
oculaire détecte automatiquement les
consoles grâce aux quatre ports hdmi qui
sont 2 points 1 sur nos tv et donc on a
un accès rapide avec la détection de la
console en question on va y aller tout
de suite j'arrête de vous utilisez et
puis on atterrit donc du coup sur le
premier jeu je me reconnecte il faut que
tu te reconnais qd je pense que j'ai
trop parlé
tu as mal est éteinte
acn billets tout qu'est exactement et on
va rentrer dans le vif du sujet alors
je sais pas pourquoi il faut que tu
appuies sur commencé voilà tout
simplement
et là on est directement dans la
cinématique de nba touquet alors on peut
le voir c'est assez bluffant florent je
pense que tu as tu peux tu peux
carrément te plonger dans le stade on
est tous les deux grands fans de basket
donc ça nous parle permanent je sui team
lebron j'espère que tu m'as mis lebron
on verra on verra je vais c'est
peut-être chalenge et tu m'as parlé
d'âge écoute moi j'ai peut-être plus
teamsters curie show un peu au début de
ma carrière peut-être peut-être c'est
vrai et j'en profite peut-être pour pour
signaler qu'en plus de la détection
automatique donc le téléviseur va se
mettre sur un mode gaming automatique
donc
on va pouvoir après par la suite régler
ces paramètres là mais en fait le
téléviseur enfin automatiquement dès
qu'ils détectent la console est bien va
avoir des réglages en termes de fluidité
de luminosité de colorimétrie et même de
son optimale pour l'expérience du gaming
j'arrête de vous parler et on va essayer
pendant la voyeuse jouer un petit peu
effectivement voit la barre derrière
nous
on va peut-être passer les cinématiques
tu vois tu as lebron était rassuré merci
est ce que tu peux nous parler aussi de
taux de rafraîchissement ouais
effectivement alors la norme sur sur un
display gaming aujourd'hui c'est plutôt
du 144 hertz et nos tv sont tous
compatibles 140 à 144,4 hertz pardon
genre j'en perds mes mots parce que j'ai
pas envie de prendre le point et puis et
puis donc du coup ce qui fait que la
fluidité est assez impressionnante ce
qui fait aussi peut-être que que tu vas
pouvoir marquer sur cette action
hop et voilà j'ai marqué
à part les bons plans merci guillaume du
cool ça peut être la transition oui oui
encore une fois le panier ouais non en
fait j'ai l'impression que ma mallette
bugs mais finalement tu vas me dire que
dans puisqu'il n'ya pas de ya pas de
problème là-dessus effectivement on a 1
commencent déjà à trouver une excuse
ouais on a un temps de réponse pour
pourra à ma décharge qui est ultra
rapide donc ça vient pas de la manette
ça vient bien du joueur puisque en fait
y'a rien donné aucun décalage entre
entre la commande et ce qui s'affiche
sur le téléviseur je crois que j'arrive
vraiment pas à parler et à jouer en même
temps puisque je prends beaucoup trop de
points
mais auris est plus accessible pour toi
ouais ouais allez on peut essayer on ça
te va de switcher avant que moi je
laisse l'avantagé si tu veux aller
switch on est donc du coup sûr au riz on
va avoir plus tôt une expérience en
termes de d'immersion et de qualité
d'image donc effectivement je vais
reprendre la partie qui est en cours
pour vous montrer tout ça et là on voit
tout à fait la luminosité les couleurs
les alors cédé des couleurs qui sont
retravaillées
puisqu'il ya effectivement un upscaling
mais aussi une intelligence artificielle
qui travaille avec avec des systèmes
neuronaux dédié au gaming pour afficher
la meilleure qualité d'image et puis
régler tout ça aussi avec la carte
graphique de la console donc on se parle
de brr dalhem bon bref je vous passe les
détails ça rentre un petit peu trop dans
le côté technique
mais effectivement sur sur le côté image
c'est assez probants alors là on est sur
des cinématiques parce qu'on vient de
lancer le jeu et que j'ai pas eu le
temps d'aller jouer le soir florent je
travaille un peu trop le message est
entendu je plaisante bien sûr mais là
c'est un jeu pour vraiment à faire en
mode aventure à prendre du temps et là
on peut s'apercevoir effectivement de la
fluidité des couleurs
d'un gorille moi je connaissais pas du
tout et est tout à leur jeu quand je
suis venue vers vous dans le salon là
maintenant je suis bien ne juge pas
bougé je suis tranquille tu vois comme
normaux de feignasses mai mais j'ai été
hyper bluffé parce que c'est super beau
ouais c'est super beau tu as
l'impression de regarder un dessin animé
de jouer dans un dessin animé le truc
est fou quoi oui tout à fait et on se
plonge dans un univers c'est assez
déroutant est encore là tu vois on n'a
pas le son là on se parle que d'image
donc on se rend bien compte que là on
peut y passer des heures et c'est
justement un peu le piège des jeux et de
l'association que l'on peut en faire
avec le téléviseur et avec son son salon
donc ce que je comprends quand même
kevin c'est que le téléviseur nous
permet d'avoir cette qualité d image un
peu bluffante camp quand vous en parler
donc il ya quand même des téléviseurs
qui sont dédié au gaming ou alors c'est
top scaling cette qualité d'image ou
cette fluidité tout à fait alors en fait
sur toute notre gamme neo kull head on
et nextgen console ready donc elles sont
toutes compatibles avec les consoles
n'est que de nouvelles générations donc
là dessus il ya pas d y a pas de débat à
avoir mais effectivement nous on a un
modèle flagship pour le gaming qui a le
cul n90 qui lui va être un peu mieux
spéc et puisqu'il va avoir du 144 hertz
de l'aube sky lyn sur l'ia j'arrive pas
à monter
ok pour moi c'est un live ouais ouais il
n'y a pas de jeu je pense qu'il n'est
pas fait pour moi
mais oui le cul n90 va être notre
téléviseur dédié pour le gaming et qu'on
va essayer de mettre en avant pour ces
spectres là je te propose pas d'essayer
je pense que vous me compensent donc ça
actuellement les téléviseurs qu on n 90
dont tu parles sont sur le présent sur
le site de samsung points comme c'est sa
sont disponibles à la vente tout à fait
et donc les 5 121 mille abonnés
de monsieur greu peuvent l'acheter
jusqu'à minuit avec 15% de réduction
grâce au vote cheikh samsung est
effectivement à
l'activ mal ouais bon gars la tessoualle
pas exactement ces 500 nouveautés et
transition quand même super important
donc on a montré le réalisme avec
ennemis et touquet on a montré la
profondeur des couleurs des noirs le
contraste notamment éclaté n'est que
technologie mini l'aide c'est vraiment
là on voit la pleine puissance sur la
vue sur rory est donc là le dernier jeu
gardienne la galaxie c'est vraiment une
expérience 6 mai cinématographique qu'on
peut le voir ici et je laisse aux wade a
fait alors là du coup on se rentre
vraiment dans une histoire dans un
cinéma et et puis en plus de la qualité
d'image je pense que ici il est très
intéressant de se plonger dans le côté
sonore et l'environnement sonore du jeu
alors on a de la chance parce qu'avec ce
qu on n 90 en fait on a deux
technologies qui pousse un petit peu
plus le côté qualité sonore est donc on
a effectivement le côté au ts donc c'est
l'objet cracking sound qui fait que le
son va être analysée sur le téléviseur
est en fait va suivre le déplacement
d'une action que ce soit un tir que ce
soit une voiture qui passe dans notre
dos et donc du coup ça va vraiment se
suivre sur le téléviseur couplé à ça on
a du dolby atmos donc le dolby atmos
c'est effectivement le côté horizontale
du son mais aussi verticale avec les
canaux verticaux qui sont placés
derrière le téléviseur pour me faire
mentir je peux pas aller plus loin dans
ce jeu puisque je n'ai pas écouté du
coup le code qui vous saisir pour
pouvoir passer à l'étape suivante mais
je pense que je suis pas assez calé de
toute manière sur le côté sont en tout
j'ai pas été en tout cas pris pour ça
mais du coup j'invite peut-être lorraine
lorraine à nous en parler un petit peu
plus et un peu mieux sur le côté sonore
et l'immersion sonore merci kevin merci
à toi bien sûr beaucoup lorraine nous a
rejoint
juste avant de continuer sur lauren je
pense que c'est quand même assez
bluffant comme tu l'as dit aurélien de
voir le réalisme du gaming sur les
téléviseurs samsung
je crois que tu as dit que tu jouais
beaucoup sur smartphone ouais je crois
savoir que tu as un enfant grandit et il
a aimé les dessins animés à pau voilà je
pense qu'il serait peut-être temps de
switcher du smartphone vers le grand
écran et leur faire profiter ton fils on
lâche la bride c'est vrai que le truc
est intéressant parce que moi j'ai joué
pendant longtemps sur console et puis
j'ai un peu décroché et je joue
maintenant aujourd'hui sur smartphone et
là mon fils est toujours en train de
dire papa papa et copains ils ont une
console papa papa et et c'est évident
que moi j'ai eu un vrai attachement avec
les consoles j'ai joué pendant très
longtemps et le fait de pouvoir se dire
allez je me retrouve à craquer bientôt
pour se retrouver une bonne console à la
maison pour pouvoir jouer pour des idées
enfin moi j'étais vachement de souvenirs
ou août et en famille où tu joues à
différents jeux alors moi j'ai joué
beaucoup à mario party ce trouve ça
rigolo mais quand je vois des
cinématiques comme ça quand je vois des
jeux qui même le jeu te fait penser à la
cinématique tu dis c'est tellement
dingue que tu as envie d'y aller quoi
vraiment je crois que on en a convaincu
un monfils qui va être content merci
beaucoup
donc c'est vrai comme tu l'as dit kevin
dans nos téléviseurs il ya ce son qui
tourne avec la technologie au ts qui
permet de suivre un peu le mouvement des
objets et donc on a lorraine notre
spécialiste audio sont mais tu me diras
mais pourquoi le son qu est ce que vient
faire le son dans un univers télévisuel
je pense qu'il y à une association
parfaite en fait entre un téléviseur ou
un écran plat et sa barre de son les
écrans sont toujours de plus en plus
fins de plus en plus on n'accroche nos
téléviseurs au mur on sait qu'on a
toujours besoin un peu tu vois de caisse
de résonance pour avoir un bon son et
donc pour moi il
voilà quand on achète un téléviseur
samsung on doit acheter la barre de son
samsung qui va avec l'expérience globale
parce qu'ils les vidéos je vais pas
spoiler c'est toi qui vas dire mais moi
mais il évident quand un téléviseur
comme ça alors ça dépend de la taille
parce que le rêve la très grande taille
qui est posée là on peut faire encore
peu plus grand mais il est évident que
tu veux le meilleur tu veux la meilleure
expérience tu as déjà une super image tu
veux pouvoir être enveloppé par le son
et quand tu te regarde un film alors on
parle beaucoup de jeu mais quand tu te
regarde un film tu veux que le som
transporte qui soit tout autour de toi
et ça te fait une transition en 3d sont
tout à fait chez samsung c'est vrai
qu'on n'a qu'une gamme de barre de son
dédiée du coup pour à la fois le cinéma
le gaming mais aussi la musique qu'il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui écoutent de la
musique via leur barre de son donc on a
une vraie expertise chez samsung en
acoustique depuis maintenant plusieurs
années on a un centre en fait de
recherche et développement qui est dédié
à la recherche acoustique et base en
californie à être vraiment un vivier
d'ingénieurs qui sont experts sur tout
ce qui est acoustique et c'est pour ça
guillaume qu'on est leader aussi sur les
barres de son depuis huit ans maintenant
walid à en télé depuis 16 ans leader au
bar de son depuis huit ans o o bravo
équipe parce que ces voix là c'est très
belles choses donc ok donc la gamme tu
nous l'as dit elle est plutôt large mais
il ya une série en fait dans la gamme
var de son samsung qui est là qu series
et sari fait qu series qu'est ce que
c'est alors qu series en fait c'est
notre gamme de barres de son très miam
chez samsung vous l'aurez compris le
parallèle entre n'ai aucune aide et les
cuisses à nice donc ça c'est fait pour
avoir un écosystème au global le cul
series en fait vous proposer un son le
plus précis le plus enveloppants et le
plus réaliste possible donc ici vous
avez une barre de son
1990 b donc sinon dernier modèle le
modèle flagship de nos deux gammes puis
series donc 22 haut parleur un système
11.4 comme l'a dit florent tout à
l'heure donc concrètement on a onze
canaux horizontaux un caisson de basses
qu'on voit ici pour avoir des bases
vraiment puissante enveloppant des
poires vibrer dans tous ses contenus et
aussi les haut parleurs verticaux sur le
dessus à la fois sur la barre de son est
sûre les enfants arrière donc là on est
complètement plongé au coeur de son
contenu on a un son à 360 donc c'est
bien au cinéma bien sûr on a l'habitude
tous d'aller au cinéma avant d'être de
vibrer avec le son qui a mais aussi pour
le gaming puisque comme l'a dit kevin
tout à l'heure c'est hyper important à
la fois aussi dans le gaming puisqu'on
va avoir les joueurs qui arrive de
derrière de côté et du coup un son
exceptionnel va nous permettre en fait
d'être beaucoup plus performant dans
notre jeu c'est vrai que le son je me
permets de revenir tu parles du son qui
part vers le haut et ça coûte et en
commun des mortels on se rend pas compte
mais en fait le son par vers le haut et
il va quoi il va revenir vers toi il va
venir sur le plafond rebond doit venir
c'est toute la technologie donc dolby
atmos bien sûr qu'on a à la fois sur nos
téléviseurs mais surtout aussi sur nos
barres de son il va rebondir donc sur
les côtés sur le plafond sachant que nos
barres de son ce calibre automatiquement
donc en fonction de la pièce en fonction
de l'installation pour pouvoir optimiser
les réglages et la restitution sonore
parfaite mais quand vous êtes installé
notre qui veut dire que j'ai une grande
pièce où j'ai une petite pièce en fait
ça va pas changer l'histoire c'est elle
qui va faire le job pour optimiser
l'expérience qui se passe tout à fait il
ya une chose très importante dans les
culs series peut-être qui peut expliquer
c'est justement l'association entre le
téléviseur il continue de soleil
continue de collège alif la barre de son
pour moi c'est unique c'est c'est ça en
effet donc ça c'est une innovation qu'on
a lancé maintenant il y a deux ans chez
samsung c'est l'innovation qu'on appelle
qu symphonique qu symphonie pourquoi
puisque c'est l'alliance parfaite de la
barre de son est le téléviseur donc pour
ce qu'ils ne savent pas qui nous
regardent en fait normalement quand on
connecte une barre de son à son
téléviseur sa coupe les haut-parleurs du
téléviseur ce qui est dommage ici
puisque comme kevin l'a dit on à des
haut parleurs verticaux aussi à
l'arrière de nos téléviseurs dont nous
chez samsung qu'est ce qu'on s'est dit
quand on connaît que les deux produits
on va associer tous les haut parleurs
pour pouvoir avoir un son encore plus
précis encore plus réaliste est encore
plus enveloppants voilà donc toi pour
moi c'est c'est bluffant parce que quand
tu achètes une barre de son en fait tu
ne sais pas mais ça coupe les
haut-parleurs du téléviseur et
l'assassin avec une barre de son samsung
sa synchronise automatiquement et donc à
une immersion plus importante à les
haut-parleurs du téléviseur et les hauts
parleurs de la barre de son tout à fait
ça c'est et alors qu'est ce qui encore
plus bluffant satané vite et non alors
j'y viendrai après guillaume en effet on
a des produits très connectée mais ce
qui est vraiment nouveau cette année
chez samsung à une innovation c'est que
on va pouvoir aussi profiter du dolby
atmos sans fil normalement pour profiter
du dolby atmos qui est un format qui se
démocratise maintenant à la fois dans le
cinéma on a beaucoup de films de séries
en dolby atmos mais aussi dans les jeux
vidéo ça se développe énormément et même
dans la musique d'habitude il faut
connecter sa barre de son au téléviseur
via un câble hdmi obligatoirement sauf
que la plupart des utilisateurs ils
veulent moins de kabyles veulent un
système qui soit moins encombrant et
donc là c'est vraiment une petite
révolution puisque on peut connecter sa
barre de sont enrichis à son téléviseur
et quand même bénéficié de cette
restitution hyper enveloppante qui est
le dolby atmos donc ça c'est la grosse
nouveauté de cette année sur notre gamme
de barres de son cul series ses canaux
ses canons mais j'ai envie de la prendre
à la fin du live vous me laissez cinq
minutes j'embarque tout et je me pose
chez moi et je me senti la pression la
balle on la regarde vous étiez de
l'important c'est que sur les donc les
culs series voilà on a actuellement à
votre chère de -15% également sur le
site de samsung valable jusqu'à minuit
donc sur toutes les séries
toutes les cuisses et rice alors 2021
puisque la nouvelle gamme arrive le 14
avril
bientôt c'est bientôt c'est bientôt un
petit peu en décalage par rapport à la
télé mais c'est bientôt c'est bien de
l'annoncé donc le dernier point la
connectique la collectivité tout avait
donc tu l'as dit c'est important au
final la qualité sonore reste ce qu'on
recherche en premier sur une barre de
son avoir cet effet souvent mais la
connectivité pour tous nos usages c'est
aussi extrêmement important donc bien
sûr nos barres de son son bluetooth son
wifi mais du coup comme on l'a dit les
personnes écoutent de plus en plus de la
musique on a embarqué comcast et harpe
les deux donc directement via son
smartphone en wifi on peut partager
instantanément femme musique avec une
qualité il fit
avec c'est génial parce qu'en fait tu
dis alors c'est sûr que c'est évident
que ça marche avec la télé mais si tu
dis aller par exemple téléviseur éteint
mais je profitais je veux faire de la
musique l'ambiance est à la maison avec
des amis autour de l'apéro mettait pas
forcément avec la télé soit allumé ma tu
peux et fait partager rapidement comme
ça je trouve ça vachement bien donc ça
ça rajoute encore plus à l'usagé et à
l'expérience et c'est très important
d'avoir une expérience la plus simplifié
possible c'est aussi là dessus qu'on
travaille chez samsung et je terminerai
quand même avec une petite touche design
puisque je m'occupe aussi de toute la
partie lifestyle donc le design est
quelque chose d'important pour moi on le
voit ici c'est quand même des produits
avec un design très contemporain
travaillé aussi pour s'intégrer
parfaitement avec nos téléviseurs
puisque là en fait on le voit ça ne va
pas du tout masquer l'écran non pas du
tout gêné le visionnage donc même sur un
produit ultra puissant en terme de
qualité sonore on reste quand même sur
quelque chose d'assez compact et facile
à installer chez soi c'est vrai que la
nouvelle gamme sort en avril bien
évidemment il ya des design contemporain
mais aussi des design plus épuré entre
guillemets plus lifestyle qui sont plus
fins et qui puisqu'ils peuvent se fondre
un peu dans son intérieur merci lorraine
merci à toi de nous avoir expliqué tout
ça on arrive presque à la fin ouais
voilà la voyance et pour une première
c'est assez rapide voilà la preuve
frustrant d'être aussi court mais merci
beaucoup pour tes remarques ben merci
beaucoup je suis très heureux d'avoir
fait cela et puis c je sais que pour
vous c'est tout nouveau et c'est une
nouveauté vous venez de lancer donc je
suis très heureux de pouvoir vous
accompagner sur 7 sur ce premier live en
tout cas sans votre chaîne youtube même
si elle est diffusée en même temps chez
moi sur sur youtube je sais combien
c'est pas évident de lancer de nouveaux
formats ô combien c'est pas évident de
prendre ces risques la stockant sais pas
c'est pas ton job c'est pas votre métier
à vous de faire des live donc
le résultat est hyper canon et puis suis
très heureux de faire ça avec vous donc
voila merci et c'est vrai on commence
une grande série j'espère tous les mois
tous les 3e semaine de chaque mois on va
faire un live avec une thématique à
chaque fois différente donc on donne
rendez vous voilà à ta chaîne à la
chaîne youtube samsung de nous rejoindre
ça c'est important et comme tu l'as dit
on veut le faire de façon simple et
passionné j'espère qu'on a commencé à le
véhiculer on veut le faire avec les
équipes samsung c'est nous en fait qui
argumente on démontrons vendons ces
produits et donc notre passion on
voudrait la faire passer comme ça pas
internet via l'intermédiaire d'autres
personnes mais voilà avec des hommes et
des femmes et qui on travaille tous les
jours et voilà on est assez passionné et
donc c'est important d'essayer de
montrer de le faire comme ça pour savoir
différent de ce qui existe ouais ouais
losail par canon donc ce qui est
important c'est qu'il faut qu'on ait des
abonnés rien que abonnez-vous
sur la chaîne youtube monsieur groupe
parce que je pense que c'est le début
aussi d'une belle histoire ensemble
voilà j'espère qu'on va continuer à se
voir à se rencontrer à faire évoluer
cette histoire ensemble abonnez vous sur
la chaîne youtube de samsung et puis
surtout laisser des commentaires je
pense que c'est important on a besoin de
se nourrir de vaud de vos commentaires
de vos appréciations de vos remarques
nouveau question n'y a pas de tabou on
peut répondre à tous donc voilà vous
avez le temps vous avez un mois et je
m'engage au prochain live de pouvoir
voilà y répondre et bien c'est super
canon c'est chouette merci encore merci
beaucoup merci à toi merci à toutes les
équipes nancy lorraine nancy à tout le
monde mais aussi florent et merci à vous
les viewer de nous avoir suivis pendant
ce premier live et je vous donne
rendez-vous dans un mois merci beaucoup
merci car gâteau
[Musique]